consider the density curve below it's
depicted right over here it's a little
unusual looking it looks more like a
triangle than our standard density
curves but it's valid which of the
following statements are true choose all
answers that apply
the mean of the density curve is less
than the median pause this video and see
if you can figure out whether that's
true
well we don't know exactly where the
mean and median are just by looking at
this but remember the median is going to
be the value for which the area to the
right and the left are going to be equal
so i would guess the median is going to
be someplace
like that
so that's my guess my
approximation that is the median
and because our distribution goes off
further to the left than it does to the
right you could view this as something
of a tail it's reasonable to say that
this is left skewed
left
skewed
and generally speaking if a distribution
is left skewed the mean is to the left
of the median so because it is left
skewed the mean might be someplace
like right over there another way to
even think about the mean is that the
mean would be the balance point
where you would place the fulcrum if
this were a mass
and you might say why doesn't that
happen at the median well remember even
when you're balancing something a
smaller weight that is far away from the
fulcrum can balance out a heavier weight
that is closer into the fulcrum so in
terms of this first one the mean of the
density curve is less than the median in
this case or you could say to the left
of the median we can consider this to be
true
now what about the median of the density
curve is 3.
well i already approximated where the
median might be saying hey this area
looks roughly comparable to this area
the median definitely i might not be
right there but the median is definitely
not going to be 3. this area right over
here is for sure smaller than this area
right over here so we can rule that out
the area underneath the density curve is
1. pause this video is that true
yes this is true the area underneath any
density curve is going to be one if we
look at the total area under the curve
it's always going to be one
so we answered this question i'll leave
you with one extra question that we can
actually figure out from the information
they've given us
what is the height of this point of this
density curve right over here what is
this value what is this height going to
be see if you can pause this video and
figure it out and i'll give you a hint
the hint is this third statement the
area under the density curve is 1.
all right now let's try to work through
it together
if we call
this height h
we know how to find the area of a
triangle it's one-half base times height
area is equal to one-half
base times height
we know that the area is one this is a
density curve so one is going to be
equal to what's the length of the base
we go from one to six so from one to six
this base the length of this base
is five
one-half times five times height or we
could say one is equal to five halves
times height or multiply both sides by
two-fifths
to solve for the height
and what are we going to get we're going
to get the height is equal to two-fifths
so if you have a very clean triangular
density curve like this you can actually
figure out the height with even if it
was not directly specified